how do you say the word gif I say Jeff
gif he pronounced jiff yes this is the
wrongest thing that a person can do
I said gift some people say jiff like a
bunch of dummies
yeah jiff it's not jiffy peanut butter
and jiff hijacker I I call him Jeff like
I wait you would call it a jiff
no it's gif if you say it any other way
you're wrong I've heard like computer
people say Jeff before it's kind of like
gift it's just missing the teeth but
like is gift short for something yeah
graphics interchange format that makes
sense nobody says graphics graphics is a
hard
jeet so many words are not pronounced
the way they're supposed to be but this
word should be pronounced
then you should have used a J if you
coin an abbreviation you don't get to
coin how it's pronounced jiff is fine
but it doesn't seem right I'm just gonna
call JPEG ji pegs now people could say
get people can say JIT people can say
gif or whatever they want
I mean I don't care what people do let
us know in the comments what you think
well here I say gif and so internally
place I use giving candies I like
whisper it to myself after I talked to
some I got the app my desk I'm like oh
yeah did you see that gift sounds really
good Jeff